use la propiedad distributiva para
expandir la expresión 6 que multiplica a
menos 4 w más un medio y déjenme sacar
por acá bloc de notas para que podamos
trabajar este problema y bueno lo que
quiero que te des cuenta es que este 6
de aquí lo que va a hacer es multiplicar
a toda esta cantidad y por lo tanto
déjame escribir esto de la siguiente
manera esto es lo mismo que 6 que seis
que multiplica a menos 4 w déjame
ponerlo con este color menos 4 w ya esto
le voy a sumar le voy a sumar un medio
ok
6 que multiplica al menos 4 w más un
medio y bueno esencialmente lo que
tenemos que hacer es distribuir este 6
multiplicando primero a esta cantidad y
después multiplicando a un medio y me va
a quedar lo siguiente déjame escribirlo
de esta manera
es que multiplica primero a menos 4 w
4 w y después déjame ponerlo de esta
manera 6 va a multiplicar más 6 que va a
multiplicar a esta otra expresión que es
un medio un medio de lujo y entonces
tengo esta expresión de aquí y esto va a
ser igual a 6 x menos 4 w bueno pues eso
es menos 24 w
ok y después 6 por un medio bueno pues
eso es lo mismo que 3 por lo tanto
llegué a la respuesta - 24 w
3 así que es hora de describir lo justo
por aquí tengo menos 24 w
3 am lo voy a poner aquí - 24 w y a esto
le voy a sumar 3 ok es hora de comprobar
la respuesta y de lujo estamos bien